CHRISTINE BREINER: Welcome
back to recitation.
Today we're going to
talk about something
you've been seeing
in the lectures.
Specifically, we're going
to talk about continuity
and differentiability.
And we're going
to use an example
to see a little bit
what the difference is.
That how you can be
continuous and not necessarily
differentiable.
And how it's a little stronger
to have differentiability.
So we're going to deal
with a piecewise function.
I'm going to ask
a question, I'll
give you a little bit
of time to work on it,
and then we'll come back.
So the question
is the following:
for what values of a and b is
the following function either
first, continuous, or
second, differentiable?
So the function is defined
in the following way:
f of x is going to be equal
to the function x squared
plus 1 when x is bigger than 1.
And it's going to be
equal to a linear function
where you get to pick the
a, which is the slope,
and you get to pick the b,
which is a y-intercept, if x
is less than or equal to 1.
So what I've drawn so
far, so that you can see,
is that I've drawn
the part of x squared
plus 1 if x is bigger than 1.
So I've taken the x squared
function that starts at
(0, 0)-- or the
vertex is at (0, 0)--
I've shifted it up
one unit, and then
I've chopped off everything
left of and including
the value at x equal 1.
So my question, again, is, what
choices do I have for a and b
to either first, figure out
what choices for a and b
allow this function
to be continuous
when I put in the left part-- so
the values when x is less than
or equal to 1-- and
what values for a
and b allow this function
to be differentiable?
So I'm going to give you a
moment to work on it yourself,
and then we'll come back and
I'll work through them for you.
OK.
So what we were
doing, again, is we
were trying to
answer this question,
choose values for a and
b that make-- first,
let's look at the
continuity question.
OK.
So what we really
need is, we need
to have a linear
function that ultimately
goes through this point,
whatever this point is.
We have to figure out
what that point is,
and then we can figure
out what values of a and b
will allow that to work.
So if I want a continuous
function, these a and b,
again, they have to be such
that the line goes straight
through that point.
So what is that point?
Well, the x-value is 1.
So what would the y
value have to be in order
to fill in that circle?
We can actually look at f
of x and we can say, well,
if I wanted it to be continuous,
then the y-value I need here,
I need at x equal 1, is going to
be whatever the y-value is here
at x equal 1.
So let me write that.
Make a little space over here.
So to answer question
one, I need a and b so
that at x equal 1, y is equal
to-- well, if I put in 1 here,
what do I get?
I get 1 squared plus 1.
So I get 2.
So I need y to equal 2
when x is equal to 1.
OK?
So ,in other words,
down here again,
let me just say before I go
on, this point is 1 comma 2.
So what I need is
a line that goes
through the point 1 comma 2.
OK?
So what is that?
That would be, in this case,
that would be, the output is 2,
and the input is a times--
well, x is 1-- 1 plus b.
So that means a plus
b has to equal 2.
And that actually represents
all the solutions.
So there are an infinite
number solutions I could have.
And if you think about it,
I could draw some of these,
I could draw some
of these lines.
So let's take, for instance,
b equals 2 and a equals 0.
When b is 2 and a is
0, it's the constant,
it's the constant
function f of x equals 2.
It's a straight line.
That would graph-- going
to graph that here.
That would graph
straight across,
and that would
fill in right here,
and this would be if
we had on this side,
this is f of x equals 2.
OK?
I could also have chosen
a plus b equals 2.
a equals 1 and b equals 1.
So I could have slope
1 and intercept 1.
Notice, by the way, this
one is not differentiable.
Right?
It's obviously-- there's
a significant break there.
We'll see also, with a
equal 1 and b equals 1,
it's also not differentiable.
So a equals 1 is slope 1, and
b equals 1 is intercept is 1.
That's this line.
So this is kind of
running out of room,
but f of x equals x plus 1.
Hopefully you can see that.
f of x equals x plus 1.
f of x equals 2.
This one looks a little
bit closer to being almost
like the tangent lines are
going to match up there.
But it's not quite.
And we'll see in a
second what we will need.
So this was, we answered
the continuity question.
OK.
So now let's answer the
differentiability question.
OK.
Notice, again, continuous.
We have a lot of
lines that will work.
OK.
But to answer the
differentiability question,
I need the derivative as
I come in from the left
to be equal to the derivative
as I come in from the right.
So actually, I think
I did that backwards.
This is, as I come
in from the right,
I need this derivative-- this
gives me a certain value.
As I come in from the
left, I need a derivative
coming this direction.
I need them to be the same.
That's what it would
mean for the function
to be differentiable.
I can write that in words.
The limit as x goes to 1
from the left of f prime of x
has to equal the
limit as x goes to 1
from the right of f prime of x.
I'm not sure-- I think you
saw this notation already.
Limits coming in from the left
are designated by a minus sign.
Limits coming in from the right
are designated by a plus sign.
So we need these two limits to
agree in order for the function
to have a well-defined
derivative at that point.
So let's figure
out what this is.
Because we have
the function here.
The function to the right
of 1 is x squared plus 1.
We know its derivative.
Its derivative is 2x.
So on this side,
we have the limit
is x goes to 1 from
the right of 2x.
And now we can fill that in.
What is that?
Well, I just evaluate at
x equal 1 and I get 2.
OK?
And now that means
I need the limit
as x goes to 1 from the left
of the derivative to also be 2,
so let's fill in this side.
The function on the left, at
the left of 1 is a*x plus b.
So what is its derivative?
Its derivative is just a.
Right?
Because the derivative
of b-- b is a constant.
That derivative is 0.
The derivative of this is a.
OK?
So we get the limit is x
goes to 1 from the left of a.
That's what this
left-hand expression is.
Well, if I evaluate
a at x equal 1,
I can actually just plug it in.
There's no x there.
This is a constant function, so
as x goes to 1 from the left,
I just get a.
So that tells me that
a has to equal 2 here.
OK?
So in order to make the
function differentiable,
I only have one value
of a I'm allowed to use,
and that's when a equals 2.
OK?
So I didn't draw this one, yet.
I didn't draw it on
purpose because I
wanted to save that for last.
So when a is 2,
what's b have to be?
Well, in order to
be differentiable
it first has to be continuous.
So it has to satisfy
this, a equals 2,
and it has to satisfy
this, a plus b equals 2.
So that tells me a equals 2, and
it tells me b has to equal 0.
That comes from our
work in number one.
OK?
What does that represent?
That's a line with
intercept 0 and slope 2.
So I'll draw that one last.
Goes through 0, has slope 2,
so it goes through this point.
And if I draw those,
if I connect those up,
we see, if we continued we see
that the tangent lines there
agree exactly.
But the function itself
is just this part.
It's just, the right-hand
side is x squared plus 1,
the left hand side
is y equals 2x.
So we've now figured
out how to make
this piecewise function both
continuous and differentiable.
And we'll stop there.